I'm going to call out Elon Musk for
hypocrisy we have this tweet from Shuan
head
she said Elon Musk confirms he won't
reinstate Alex Jones however you feel
about Alex Jones aside am I wrong here
like not that there was much there was
much doubt before but Elon just
completely showed his ass Elon said my
first born child died in my arms I felt
his last heartbeat I have no mercy for
anyone who would use the deaths of
children for gain politics or fame
now that's interesting Alex Jones was
not banned from Twitter for anything
related to any kids
Alex Jones was banned from Twitter
because he insulted Oliver Darcy Elon is
insulting a reporter a bannable defense
okay ban yourself uh I'll wait
is he almost gonna ban himself he's
going to shut up okay look I can respect
all of the good things he's done the
people he's unbanned and I will accept
the win what I will not accept is I will
say it this way it is not victory for
the people that we are living beneath
the whims of a billionaire what is a
victory for the people is a clear set of
rules policies and procedures so we can
all fairly understand the rules of the
platform Elon it's your platform I
understand that what are the rules if
you come out and tell me the rule is
Free Speech I say you got it boss if you
come out and say the rule is you can't
say this that otherwise will say okay
well that's dumb but you got it boss if
you come out and tell me the rules are a
but then oh by the way I have special
rules for other people well then your
your rules are garbage and completely
meaningless now what's really happening
is you're unbanning people you like
well that's a very interesting point but
what would you say to this is that
what if in practice in terms of how
things cash out it's actually
maximizes free speech on Twitter to have
an arbitrary system rather than have a
system that follows prescribed rules
because you'd have to think what kind of
prescribed rules can get he get away
with he could say what he said before
which is that the law of the land in
terms of speech will govern speech
policy on Twitter which in the U.S would
mean First Amendment
I don't know if that's practical given
the implications I understand that so
let's say let's ask where the line is
insulting a reporter is that a bannable
offense
is that is that is that in need of
flexibility
I think they would all need flexibility
but I think it's easier to think in
terms of who would be let back on versus
kind of neutral principles that are kind
of Applied
retroactively in practice he can get
away with more if he pursues the
arbitrary of course of course in terms
of maximizing free speech on Twitter and
he's giving himself a legal argument
here because he's outright saying that
for this personal reason he will not be
reinstating Alex Jones I will stress I
absolutely uh feel and sympathize with
Elon over this feeling of losing his son
I mean it's a horrifying thing to have
to experience and I can I can respect
and understand that I just don't know
what it has to do with Alex Jones
insulting a reporter now if we're going
to argue there needs to be some
flexibility sure but some things are
within the bounds of the Overton window
and fine insulting a reporter you don't
get banned for it now if you're arguing
that there's harassment and what
constitutes harassment okay now we're
dealing with something more difficult
well I'm saying more that at this stage
at least in practice this his assessment
and he could very well be right on this
is that he can't get away with allowing
Alex Jones on and he is probably
um imprudent and I think he probably
stepped Over The Line in attacking Jones
the way he did but the reality is
probably he couldn't get Jones on and
that's the cost of doing all the other
stuff that he's done perhaps I
understand that but I'm not going to
apologize for for Elon of course not I
will accept the victories right and
we're seeing tremendous victories it's
it's funny we're it's fun we're laughing
there's jokes there's memes and all Elon
had to do was not address the issue
outright it's probably the safest thing
for him to do is like he's not addressed
Carl Benjamin we all want him on band
he's not addressed Milo but he did
specifically address Alex then said he's
not going to unban him because he did a
thing six years prior to his Twitter ban
that offends Elon Annette right there I
get it maybe he's gonna have a legal
argument in the future that I that
clearly shows I will ban whoever I want
for whatever reason there's no rules
whatsoever and by doing so so if he does
ban you you can't sue him for breach of
contract because he he's clearly
operating on a win I'm happy he's at
least telling us where his flawed
decision is coming from because it's a
illogical decision that shows you that
there's no Pathway to Redemption and
he's using emotional trauma in order to
justify this larger Banning for
something that Alex Jones has already
apologized for something that Alex Jones
is being fined 1.5 billion dollars for
something that of course cost Alex Jones
almost everything but but at the end of
the day here if we're going to be
punishing people for using children for
their own political gain or fame uh my
original response to this was hey Elon
Musk have you heard of uh Barack Obama
the guy who dropped uh a bomb every 20
minutes for for eight years the guy who
judicially extra extrajudiciously
assassinated a 16 year old American
citizen if we're going to be punishing
people for hurting children we might as
well ban the president of the United
States let's not even get into big
Pharma we don't even have to go into
Bitcoin come on there a minute Joe Biden
out there groping and sniffing kids
right now you gonna ban them that's a
lot different than dropping a bomb on
small children I get it I'm saying
Obama's not the president anymore so we
have that argument so ban him obviously
and Joe Biden who's currently the
president is on camera groping and
sniffing children so how about we have a
standard oh that's the problem there's
no standard is there any off-platform
Behavior warrants a ban nope well this
is what Jack Conte of uh what's a
patreon uh argued specifically he he
created this new term off platform
Behavior off-platform off off yeah yeah
off platform Behavior which is
absolutely ridiculous because again
you're going to arbitrarily say you did
this 10 years ago or 20 years ago I
don't like that culture culture but but
again
my personal preference which I hope
ultimately he'll be able to achieve is
the first amendment standard but he's a
lot more practical than I think people
realize and the First Amendment standard
it sounds something like something very
easily publicly defensible when you put
it that way but then you say okay first
amendment standard means all legal
speech that means that probably the most
banned people on the internet
like Andrew Anglin has to go on Twitter
I'm for that because I'm for the First
Amendment standard but as a matter of
practical reality that's a hell of a lot
of incoming that Elon would have right
up front and so what kind of principles
can you pick that would cash out better
at least in this initiative
don't say you believe in free stuff if
the assumption is that uh perhaps he's
playing a game of 40 chest three yes and
then he then he should not have
addressed the issue at all because if
your argument is he has to to play the
game that means he's virtue signaling
right don't care for virtue signaling I
don't care for being lied to and I don't
care for petty uh I I don't care I
shouldn't say it that way but I don't
care for personalized arguments as to
why certain people are below the
standards I agree I I think he shouldn't
have gone there and said oh you know use
the kid thing
um that was unfortunate and cross the
line line and uh and he clearly doesn't
know anything about it sorry to
interrupt right no I agree no I I'm
totally with you there I want the First
Amendment standard I'm just trying to
put myself in Elon shoes and I'm
thinking as much as we want a kind of
neutral principled standard such that we
can say well if you do this what about
this which is you know how fairness
operates
um but in terms of the result the kind
of consequentialist uh view of it is
that he can actually probably maximize
Free Speech more if he does virtue
signal a little bit at least in these
early stages there was there was
something infuriating uh about Jack
Dorsey and vajayagade lying to your face
when you were like hey why was this
person banned and why wasn't this person
when you'd say something like hey look
here's an antifa account advocating for
instructing violence and they go oh well
it's a mistake and then they still won't
take it down
when they tell you we're working on it
there will be a path of redemption I
hear you I hear what you're saying we're
going to try and fix it it's frustrating
because you know they're lying to you
it's even worse when it's a billionaire
who just says too bad
like it's one thing to be like I can I
can I can I can hold on to that one
percent hope that Jack Dorsey means it
when he says we're gonna find a way to
get people back on the platform we got
to figure out how to do it it's another
thing when Elon Musk is like I bought it
it's mine too bad there's no rules I can
do whatever I want and if we can't trust
them on this what makes you think we
can't trust them on on other issues as
well this brings a lot of doubt and
speculation because he's acting on
emotion rather than morals and virtues
rather than saying hey I believe in free
speech that means speech for people I
despise he says no I don't like him but
but Elon have you heard of uh a thing
called Epstein's Island there's a former
president there that used to attended
Bill Clinton he's also on your platform
right now if you care about children and
children you would be going after them
but he's not and and having this kind of
made-up scenario where you say he's okay
but he's not good based off your own
emotional trauma is not something that
gives me a lot of Hope in this platform
moving before we all agree that the
first amendment should be the ultimate
standard Free Speech no I disagree you
did I think I think even higher for
Twitter I disagree and on one issue
docson okay there's probably enough uh
the First Amendment doesn't cover
criminal acts there's there's challenges
to whether or not something can be
deemed uh criminal of its speech so so
first amendment minus doxing not
necessarily so listen
uh the first some people are free speech
absolutists they believe that words can
never be criminal no matter what you
said that means literally they think
incitement to violence and instruction
on how to do horrible things and there's
an interesting point there
if we argue that there is Criminal
speech in any capacity we're arguing
Congress can pass a statutory law
criminalizing speech that makes no sense
right
so the Supreme Court upheld upholds
basically that if you incite violence
that is not protected by the First
Amendment now my question is I
understand that I understand the
arguments but how does that make sense
Congress isn't making the law the
Supreme Court just said as we interpret
what the first amendment is supposed to
mean we've carved out an exception about
the founding fathers in Covenant
exception so there's an interesting
argument there because if we do agree
that incitement of violence is is
Criminal and not free speech what
happens if Congress or the Supreme Court
what happens to the Supreme Court for
instance rules that actually hate speech
is incitement because of stochastic
terrorism are we going to continue to
allow the courts to decide if there are
more larger and larger limits to speech
so I don't know that
um also saying the First Amendment
standard is not good enough because it's
subject to Future kind of modifications
from the Supreme Court's sort of
interpretive because the freeze because
the First Amendment
could be argued to mean you can incite
to violence and so there's limits Beyond
so my point is this
in the future the Supreme Court May rule
that doxing someone is not free
expression it's a it's it's actually a a
a attack against or something it's a
violation of someone's privacy and thus
criminal it would be interesting if
Congress ruled that posting someone's
private information this this may be a
court that has a case that has to be
adjudicated actually if Congress tries
passing a law saying posting someone's
private home details or or private
information phone number contact Etc uh
without their permission constitutes a
crime the Supreme Court is going to
determine whether or not that violates
Free Speech because posting someone's
address doesn't really express your
political opinion or views and that's an
argument some people make about what
free speech is anyway I don't want to
over make it overly complicated the
first amendment is an easy thing to say
but we really do need bullet point
breakdown of what is okay and what isn't
uh Gaba for instance I believe bans
doxing okay and that's free speech you
could walk around with a big old sign
with someone's address on it but on gab
you can't do that I agree I don't think
you should be allowed to post someone's
private details I don't think there
should be permanent bans for these
things however because you know I argue
this to Jack Dorsey there are people who
commit murder and they get out in 25
years sure there's a guy who who you
know posted a nasty Meme and you've
permanently removed his ability to speak
in the public there's no Redemption and
right according to the
um Theology of cancellation I just want
to point out the Clinton Global
initiatives on Twitter
you know yeah there's a lot of war
criminals and monsters there's you know
terrorist organizations that are on
there openly using the platform without
any kind of problems when Twitter a
couple years ago was looking at of
course right-wing talking points that
they needed to censor and take down so
uh it's crazy because this this is a
very important issue and and we can't
underplay it because yes I mean we got
to celebrate our victories Elon did
incredible things on Banning a lot of
important people that were uh punished
for their political speech but if you're
going to continue the punishment based
on your own kind of made up uh standards
that that's something that doesn't give
me hope that's something that I think a
lot of people should be skeptical of and
I think that's something that a lot of
people should be criticizing him on
because obviously it doesn't stand with
any kind of virtue thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time